why did the splash screen say ubisoft
poon what does that mean what is a pune
and why is it
affiliated with ubisoft i don't know man
all right why is this resolution so
wonky
oh my god fatal error
oh no oh i tried to change the
resolution and it did not
like it i don't know what happened but
it's frozen again
oh
but i've got the world's smallest window
even though it says it's in 1920
i had that problem you got to go through
a few fatal errors but it'll work itself
out
you keep killing it eventually it'll
reincarnate and yeah exactly
green but it's on like a four by four
like little bomb
yeah yeah it happens happens the best of
all ubisoft
i'm in baby am i a [ __ ] yeah all right
hat
what sweet mark if you join the game we
can commence
oh [ __ ] i didn't no i'm so sorry
what an actual remove this man
oh now i should not start the game yes
no
star game not star game yes big monitors
that my game could be
this big why do you still have that big
stupid monitor that breaks all of your
games
no you do why do you play at 4k
i don't or tv it's not a minor it's a tv
screen you're using a tv
he's using a big ass tv to use a tv send
an email to someone or something
these are asus monitors oh asus mounted
there's
i'm about to beat this watch this [ __ ]
my mouse cannot scroll to the right
oh god damn it what a
roll what a dweeb more like it
it's not like i have a choice did bob
win one for once wow
i get to go first i'd never do that why
aren't you ripping him apart
he got a lower dice than i did you're
not giving him the [ __ ] he's having a
bad enough time with his stupid tv
monitor and
yeah you're right you're right you're
right
you're right you're right i like the
living map i like how
pixely and how much aliasing there is on
all the moving parts it is nice
it is nice
stupid ghost stupid wow
okay guys i got a double guys
wow that's pretty much the best thing
you can do in this game
so i'm pretty sure i'm killing it right
now i have one second
prize in a beauty contest i can read i
can read
we can read no we can't please for me
okay
[Applause]
now let me show you how a real puss
rolls
i didn't really shake them much hey
you're coming to visit my
property
no come stay in my framed up house
that's not even really a thing
yet uh it's raining tonight
thank you i guess i let you stay on my
property you owe me you owe me that much
you owe me
oh yeah okay i'm not gonna land there
i've got
better numbers to roll
my controller has it turned off
oh look at that one shot
that says collect this is gonna be one
of those games mark dude's winning right
now
you believe this i can feel it already i
can feel it already this is gonna be one
of those
bankrupts right now you might save my
eyes 10 more years of strain
that's not where you want to be oh no
no that's where you want to be you guys
want to come stay at my dope i don't
know
i got an even doper ass problem
i stayed at your properties they are
really pathetically bad please roll a
three
i will not go away get out of here i'm
going straight
to the good spot this pussy's going on a
long walk
this place is going places baby
yeah that's this is the property this is
the good [ __ ]
tennessee that's what i wanted as they
say
in tennessee that's good stuff all right
uh
yeah i do i don't know wow look at that
pile of garbage that
is a property that is what they call the
value
that's where miley cyrus was partying
before the party in the usa
i think tennessee is probably still
counted as part of the usa but
no before partying this song that's a
total of 15. does that mean i get the
real room no not the railroad
listen wait a moment oh i love the
railroads
i'll give you all my money pennsylvania
wait i will suck nothing but i
would take it if you were giving it to
me you know what this is a fair offer
i'll
think about it mark okay good good oh
look at that
sick ass nine guardians
i teleported to free parking how about
that jesus christ jason bourne all right
here we go
that's what i thought the good moves are
good moves good moves it's a good move
good move good move good move good move
wait no oh that is great no that's a
good thing good
[Music]
you broke bastard it's gonna be one of
those games
gonna be one of those games guys it's
gonna be one of those games all right
wade
oh here we go i'm about to oh no
wow what a roll or power i'm right
between you two and i'm gonna take a red
that no one will land on the rest of the
game
no no the reds are worth a lot you
should definitely invest a lot of money
in the reds there no one ever plans on
these ever
well yeah you're right give it to me
wait you might as well just give it to
me oh that's a compelling offer uh wait
um
instead of giving it to mark for free
i'll give you 10 for it
i'll give you i will let you pet me
because i'm a cat that violates
social distancing rules with a glove you
have to wear a glove and a mask
you have to wear a glove and a mask
really just rolling out of
oh
[Music]
give it give it give it give it give it
give it give it do it
give it money will blow is that what the
sign said
money money will blow that is really
nice
you know what they mean are they making
they're macking in that fountain
yeah dude wait you couldn't see it but
they're really mac
they're real tiny so it doesn't oh my
god
oh boy oh boy we're just
zooming around old zoomy boy over here
this doesn't seem very
fair yeah i rigged it i picked the mode
where the person who hosts the game
always wins
i would believe that i would and i
choose to i choose to believe that
that is 100 a thing that i would do no
questions that
i can't believe you i like how it says
be careful as if there's a
single goddamn thing you could do okay
oh man
i'm just absolutely crushing you guys
right now i'm racing around
full blast yeah i can see that i can see
it
i started playing vox populi again
recently they're migrating up to a new
map and they got a new whole new thing
coming out because they're updating to
1.16 1.17 but i was reminded of the app
the drunk minecraft episode where
we had to collect the iron blocks and
bob kept stealing ours and hiding in a
chest in the water
yeah yeah i remember and then on the big
reveal because i'm
oh [ __ ] you i've got seven blocks and
bob's like i have 48 blocks
yep it's not my fault i'm smarter than
everyone
you rigging this game no it's a
long-winded way of saying
you got it yeah any game that bob can
steal from the
others and not put the real work in
that's that's the game that bob really
really gets the good good juice going i
swear it's where i excel
if we're honest yes i think this is
bob's property i'm gonna have to pay
some
rent you know what it totally is wait
what
six dollars well green is the second
best color next to blue
so i don't know what you expected
[Music]
railroad and a red i feel like i should
just bankrupt now
oh oh i forgot about that
complete nonsense rules of movement oh
look at this i get another of these
beautifully
valuable uh properties over here by the
big whale two properties of peace and
bob's at six
yes that is what's happening i think
that's what you're it's your mouth right
your mouth is somewhere right
you dig good mouth yep you're about a
double fur
big me okay not a double where does that
put me
nice double i think that was that was
that is that
patrick's day oh well you know
let's see how much money i owe the
government now
go to jail go to jail oh
it's gonna be one of those games guys
one of the games
i was so close to go doubles
oh god you all suck is it double for
landing on go
i don't know is that a thing not unless
you said it to be a thing
[Music]
this is dumb oh
doubles wait no seven hang on this seems
familiar could you spare some doubles
please no oh there goes that 200 bucks
he just got
dang darn it shoot gosh roll the double
and join me
join me wayne jail
i don't want to be free
you absolute crooks how bad did you
rig this game that wasn't lost
to jail that was a very long that was a
horrible turn i mean it could be worse
hey look guys i got busts
damn it oh i got to pick one square five
squares
one square gives you monopoly yeah i
think i think you're right i should
definitely get that monopoly going
oh my god you can actually do that yeah
oh my god
look at that color set complete oh my
god it's unbelievable
wade we have to team up and even then i
don't think we could win
we're gonna get out of jail and we're
gonna run right into these houses
i hope you do boys
yeah all right we'll just leave him
we'll just leave him like that oh thank
you
thank you i'm going to take it
all right can i pay 50
after i roll no i don't think so i don't
know
i'm just gonna go cause i gotta get
moving or else bob's gonna scoop up
every popular 1980's come on please
no no okay we're good we're good we're
good we're good we're ready to pass
where do i go where am i going am i
going to my place god i'm going up the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right thanks buddy
you guys should really buy some
properties yeah i think you're playing
this game
oh bye ah god i knew i forgot something
of course okay all right i think you're
missing the strategy of you right
definitely
i was this is very silly of me oh 11 oh
12.
yellow i don't even own one of those yet
so is it mine
no it's not mine no it's a lot to do why
would it be
mine buy it
there we go man i'm so good at monopoly
all right this is the round it around
this is the one where is this going
is this landing on the one you just
bought is it oh my
god visit me yes
can i sleep in the ditch outside how
much does that cost i wish there was a
game mode where your options on this
screen were either pay
or slit his throat and hide the body oh
murderopoly okay good you wanna trade
never mind too late i forgot
all right here we go big numbers
dude nice roll
oh it's 11 okay why do you
that's not owned by me so probably no
one owns it then why do you get all the
symbol dice on the right and we get the
numbers like
i just i don't know man it's so weird
it's really weird
dude maybe screaming into second place
right now
late is absolutely locked down the only
position that's up for grabs
look i got monopoly on oh and a double
that's
great that's really cool oh thank god no
it's the last
green it's the last screen oh wow praise
you know what i am running into the
problem of owning too many proper
you need to visit my properties or i'm
never gonna make this money back
right right of course yeah going to pass
go we know that
we can't do it but you can i totally got
this i'm definitely not going to land on
boardwalk
uh how much is that seven that's all
right no wait that's a
little brown place oh you got another
monopoly
oh wow so sweet damn it
do i do i buy it or do i auction it
that's the real question do you want to
invest
i just get it
[Applause]
i have a compliment color set my eye
twitch is back i don't know what caused
this but my eye twitch is all of a
sudden back
man these are so cheap to just just do
this on
what a time to put a time to be alive
he's just like that's how we create our
legacy you're gonna waste houses on the
brown product
i'm just defending yeah get your 200
from go and then hand it right into mine
i'm just
i'm just offended you know wait i'm just
offended look at those
garbage heap houses a hotel would look a
lot nicer i'd be a little bit more
inclined to stay
all right this is just much better
are you happy now yeah there we go
that's what i'm talking about
wait i want you to put money down on the
odds of me landing
listen mark you're set up right now
perfectly to definitely get boardwalk on
your next turn
i don't think you need to worry about it
for second place to submit my legacy
wait you are just absolutely crushing
second place right now
i think i think uh my my chat is calling
yeah i need frames my game is
really buggy right now my name is super
no no
oh man my frame rate is really janky i
don't know what the deal is i think it's
all right
i don't know it's super weird you didn't
have to knock over my piece
you didn't have to well that was kind of
savage hey oh
wow yeah that's oh no park places
that's really cool mark you see how
wade's operating you see what he's doing
he should take notes i should take notes
really all right another double another
double another
do i spend my last dollar on this thing
no go for it fight each other come on
don't make us
fight each other just do this no you
could come to some sort of gentleman's
agreement
i'll do one i guess that's fine damn you
bob
dammit
i just don't like how much you enjoy
come on
all right well you could totes have it
then oh
gosh you deserve this thank you
thank you thank you i should have just
bought it and then sold it to what he is
for 150 i didn't know it was such a
profit in the property
all right well i'll just play my doubles
i guess oh look at that sweet sweet
seven
is that is that an unowned red nose it's
something unowned
oh it's an orange i live but i don't
even think i can afford it no i can't
i'm too poor we've got him now ah
gosh started
come on let's just skip ahead let's just
get let's
spend your money come on i have two poor
two poor for that
sorry all right come on beat each other
up
yeah come on come on oh my gosh
mark you're really gonna want this one
since you have the uh yeah the other one
uh-huh
uh-huh i think that's really gonna pay
back for you i'm gonna pass go
i'm gonna get my red dice and you guys
are gonna
feel my wrath oh no he did it
where's that going that's board walking
next
the comeback is back on i let you have
that orange you could give that to me
no you let you have it thank you for
letting me have it at 100
over its value thank you so
generous is that deal oh
you could go die i didn't do anything to
you and i know what you're so mad at me
about it's you trickling down on me i
can feel the trickles
that's a decent little roll where does
that put you my goodness
god damn it yes give me the money
you had to push him to put hotels on it
it could have not worked out for him but
hey so
much for your money i appreciate that
i've passed go
twice and gotten zero dollars i haven't
passed go
at all why do you get the doubles
i can't believe i rolled another double
unbelievable
i got the bus all right who
who owns what tell me uh i own kentucky
i think it's the only one i own where
does nine put me
oh wait no i definitely was right
definitely mine is
yellow yeah give me that that's that's
the good stuff
yeah yeet hey mark no
no listen hey come on man come on you
can't afford it right now you can't
afford it right now anyway
can't afford it all right okay all right
i think
large numbers my friend i am thinking so
big
think about so many dots i've never
thought bigger
i've never thought bigger that might be
the last lightning yeah yeah all right
this is my comeback
this is a this is a competition
bob before you even say it the answer is
no we're not trading
we're not swapping before you decide
come on
mm-hmm what if i give you both yellows
for both light blues what about that
you want to own one whole spro no i want
to own one whole half of the entire
board
you would you would own yeah you would
own one and a half sides
i know i don't know what no three
yellows
the yellows all the yellows you say dude
all the yellows all the yellows no
more thinking about how much of an
advantage that would mean you could
afford
ooh monopoly man well you're gonna get
yourself some
some uh yeah power company electric
company that's a good one
i thought it was orange nope
it's a power company
those aren't equally as good why would
you be upset by that yeah
oh i got the boss that god i'm
definitely just gonna go get that
railroad i think all right watch out
i've got boardwalk i know i know but
i've got
the short line okay i just i don't
unders
all right so guys all right mark think
big numbers again why do you have to
watch out man have you done this why
have you gotta be
real careful why have you done this come
on just roll
just roll a good roll let's do it hey
look i might not be oh
i got a red man little man you're gonna
get your last orange bud yeah oh
yay look at me my
dick is huge my puss is fat
all right what's the button
up baby welcome to
nice yeah spend it all you don't need
cash keep going
you want big come on that's so smart
that doesn't seem smart but i've never
been known as being smart
i'm going i have to because the jump
between two and three houses is so big
all right it is big okay all right
i almost pressed delete you're going to
absolutely
crush my spirits yeah yeah yeah okay all
right
oh wait no it's way this way wait come
on please wait come on come on wait wait
wait come on wait i was kidding myself
wait come on wait wait wait come
[Applause]
immediately pays off
oh no babies it hurts
it hurts way you had second place sewed
up so neatly until just this last turn
oh wait what happened to you i thought
you were a winner
yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes ah now i might
now i must rent it safely into my own
properties
what a relaxing stroll please please
please please please please
oh that's all six i'm safe oh yeah
oh totally fine give me those 200 buck
arenas let's get this done
what were you afraid of the fifty dollar
fee yeah welcome
no luxury time darn it
what you get for being so rich i'm so
rich
oh oh you're headed toward you and then
a little
bit of mark all right oranges are bad
news
all right okay flood my fat puss with
your nose
no it only works when i say cause i'm
actually a cat oh you it just sounds
weird
i'm a hat together we could be cat in
the hat you're
you can't say the words fat puss like
you just can't get away with it come on
mark let's do it
oh monopoly
i like that it gives you no information
about that just boom
huh wade the reds are still up for grabs
oh i have a turn i forgot
a little man wow what a roll
that's not bad don't worry it's probably
safe probably good yeah what could
happen in community
channels please be kind
hey i'll take it and then you get to
come visit my properties next
all right this game's turning around
let's get started see mark you just
gotta hang in there yeah just gotta hang
in there
who are good people luck's gonna go
luck's gonna go looks gonna go
washa
how are you feeling about those uh
yellows
you know i might be i might be spicy for
the yellows i might be
i might be i might be spicy i might be a
little spicy for the yellows what if
what if i propose a big trade okay i'm
listening
i we you give me the cash to cover this
550 debt
and i give you both yellows for both
light blues so basically
you forgive the debt and we make
swapsies i feel like you still make out
on that
my gut is telling me it's not the best
deal
but i feel like that's just a net gain
for you because i wouldn't have done the
trade anyway then and then i'm
not getting the money from your debt but
do you not agree that having oranges and
yellows
what what happened you got all my stuff
what you just went bankrupt what
happened what
no are you [ __ ] kidding me i'm in
second place
i hate ubisoft so [ __ ] much
that was such a good game god damn it
was there a countdown timer for that
it must have been like some countdown
timer [ __ ] i didn't see when it was
just like waiting for bob to play and
then it was suddenly just like boom
bankrupt
[ __ ] talking that's so dumb and
you're the one hosting it why would it
happen to you hosting it
all right you want to start another game
because that's that's
that's so unfair well i mean you're kind
of ruling out my possibility of my
comeback
i suppose you're right you know what
your comeback has come
your comeback the the comeback king
first
that's such a that's such a dick smash
what the [ __ ] that's i'm so sorry bob
that sucks that was a good game
well do you guys want to play more
[Laughter]
[Music]
monopoly
now
[Music]
you